retrouvez cette semaine au cinéma les
yeux d'elsa une programmation jeune
public qui s'inscrit dans un festival
dont on est partenaire cette année
encore qui est télérama enfants nous
organisons deux événements ce week end
samedi 2 et dimanche 3 mars
nous commencerons par une journée
japonisation à 14 heures marie est la
fleur de la sorcière suivi à 16 heures
du dernier mamoru hosoda mirail ma
petite soeur et enfin pour la première
fois et sur les écrans en france l'un
des premiers films de jeux d'hayao
miyazaki le château de cagliostro
ensuite dimanche 3 mars nous vous
proposerons une avant-première à 16h30
d'un très très joli film d'animation qui
s'appelle tito et les oiseaux réalisé
par gustavo steinberg
c'est un film d'animation brésilien
alors qui reprend une partie de la crise
politique que vit le résident
actuellement
alors ce n'est pas du tout un film à la
remise ou larmoyant mais il est quand
même question pour un groupe d'enfants
intrépides de sauver le monde et de
vaincre la peur qui finalement en
gangrène
le brésil est le monde je suis immunisé
contre la peur par ce jour là j'ai
décidé que plus jamais je n'aurais peur
et que je prouverai que mon père avait
raison pour les oiseaux
[Musique]